No social critic is more withering
toward identity politics and cancel
culture than the playwright and
comedian Andrew Doyle.
Whether it's creating Titania
McGrath, the Twitter parody
of a woke twentysomething poet,
or penning a bestselling defense of
free speech.
The Oxford educated and openly
gay Doyle never misses
an opportunity to show the folly
of political correctness.
He sat down with Reason to talk
about his forthcoming book, The
New Puritans How the Religion
of Social Justice Captured
the Western World.
Andrew Doyle, it's good to be
talking to you again.
Thanks for talking to Reason.
Thanks for having me.
Nice to see you.
Let's you know, we've we've talked a
couple times over the past few years
on similar although, you
know, disparate themes, but they
all revolve around kind of
wokeness, political correctness,
conformity as the
enemy of the good society,
of critical thinking, of
of anything that approaches
progress.
The new book, which is
I'll just say, editorialized at the
beginning, is a phenomenal read.
It's a learned read that
is, you know, it
makes it's creamed spinach.
It tastes delicious while
also giving you fiber and
and much needed minerals and
vitamins. So it's the new
Puritans have the religion
of social justice captured
the western world.
What is the
elevator pitch?
So you are with one of
your heroes, Roald Dahl, in
the glass elevator
that shows up at Charlie
and the Chocolate Factory.
What do you define the book,
quickly in an elevator pitch.
I mean, in an elevator pitch, it's a
fact. I mean, I suppose the pitch
relates to the reasons why I wrote
the book. And I think we are
at a stage now in this culture
war or whatever we want to call it,
where many, many people are baffled.
They you know, there's this movement
that is sort of seize control of all
of our major institutions, be they
political or academic or the media
over in the UK, the
NHS even, the army, the judiciary,
absolutely everywhere seized power
and control in a way that the
political correctness movement of
the eighties and nineties never did.
And this is the major distinction
between the two.
And yet the movement and we can see
most people can sort of see
that this ideology has
regressive elements, is taking
us back, taking us to some very dark
places, that it is a illiberal, that
it is divisive, all the rest
of it. And yet people are confused
because it uses language that
describes itself in the opposite
terms.
So it is a movement that is grounded
in what they call social justice,
and yet it works against true
social justice.
It uses phrases like anti-racist,
which of course everyone wants to
get on board with because we're all
opposed to racism.
And yet people can see that, oh,
hang on a minute. Suddenly we have
people, schools, segregating
children by skin color
in the name of this anti-racism.
What's all that about?
It uses words like equity and people
think that sounds great as well
because they think it's the same as
equality.
It calls itself progressive when it
is regressive, it calls itself
liberal when it is illiberal.
So ultimately,
the more I've read and thought about
this, the more I realized that the
culture war of the present is really
a battle about language and who gets
to control definitions of words.
And so in order to combat it,
there's an extra shield, if you
like. You know, you can't just
challenge the ideas that are being
presented in the way that in a
traditional method,
through the Socratic method or
through traditional evidence led and
enlightenment values, because this
movement has is impervious
to reason and that is a deliberate
aspect to it.
And also, its
practitioners have the habit of
redefining language
so that you end up,
they can basically dance around the
salvoes of their critics because
when you try and criticize them,
they say, Yeah, but the words you're
using to criticize us
don't mean the things you think they
mean.
So the book has been
written hopefully to make all this
accessible.
In other words, I'm using a number
of analogies.
I call it the religion of social
justice. I think using the analogy
of religion is very a very
accessible way to make sense
of this.
For most people I'm comparing it to,
I call them the New Puritans because
I believe it is a kind of purity
culture.
It's a culture that has expectations
of moral purity in
line with what
these ideologues believe to be
morally pure.
I have to sort of caveat that
so I'm using those analogies, I'm
talking through the various
language, the origins of the
movement, where it's come from, how
it sees control.
I give innumerable
examples of where you seize control.
You know, when people say there is
no culture war, it's a right-wing
myth. Well, I've layered example
upon example in the footnotes.
And I should have you point out
are you are not a man of the right.
No. No, I'm not.